hey guys great oh I give everything to
go in Chris Hardwick okay Joel McHale
I'm tapping the minds of some of the
greatest late-night talk show hosts
currently find out what they think about
and have advice on in terms of posting
late-night talk shows thank you for very
big yeah that's on the show so let's say
an interview isn't going well and if you
can feel tension and awkwardness yes you
have like that usually what I do is
start to sweat you poop your hand and go
look what I made then people focus on
how much you're sweaty and then they
don't focus on how bad the interview is
because that'll make them forget
everything that happened up to that
point and it allows you to reset the
interview it's not bridge yeah thank god
you're doing the best you can do they
say all those things cool which I'm
doing night courses skipped over the
hand [ __ ] at jetan okay how do you deal
with an ogre talker uh you have to
interrupt
and just keep interrupting it's like a
river of words and you throw a stick
interrupt oh yeah because your audience
counts Andy Cohen told me as well that's
to choose give me advice come on if
someone's talking too much [ __ ] great
you just sit back and just and just let
it happen
it's why you're on this video this is
happening right now I talking too much
right now
you talk more words are coming here you
get fan mail
no what are my crutches is I just go to
the phones a lot for any other
ungettable get some kind of celebrity or
person that you would love to have on
the show that you haven't met yet Oh
working out the first lady for a couple
years we would really like her I would
like the first lady of my life who's
Madonna oh my god that would be amazing
analytics I would freak out well it'd be
great if we could get Taylor Swift and
Katy Perry and Justin Bieber at Pitt and
Angelina Jolie Kanye West jay-z and
Beyonce if they can all come on the show
once that would really help ratings
three words bill [ __ ] Murray Hillary
is an 800 number and I've never called
it because I've reversed it in my head
oh hi it's Chris Hardwick I'm on top now
that's dumb
Oh bill this is Chris I'm doing a
podcast that doesn't sound right a
bummer I'm not gonna murder you like I
don't know how to start the message what
is something you've learned in all of
your years of interviewing people that
you shouldn't worry about the only thing
I know okay yes I don't know
you know that's my catchphrase I see the
secret of my success is being dumped the
best advice anyone ever said when you
walk away from a show it's never as
great as you thought that it was and
it's never as horrible really valid by
solid medium right Parsons have you
learned one thing that you should be
worried about no there's no words in
here it's just drawings of dicks Oh Joe
thank you for being here so much good
luck you're an equal BrahMos
wow this took
I'll take it thank you very much good
turn just page after page this one just
says to do and then just like a bunch of
dicks with checkboxes fine I'll make
sure you check out the soup if you want
to you don't have to yeah you do if you
further they say invaluable advice good
luck with your show opus big hit